excellencies dear colleagues ladies and
gentlemen I think it is very
encouraging to listen to the
distinguished different speakers
today because we all feel that this is a
moment of intense and renewed
cooperation between Africa and
Europe because not only our Destinies
are aligned but also our interests are
aligned more than ever before
and we've heard it we all need to switch
to clean energy and to adapt to the
climate
change we all need to train our
Workforce for the jobs of
Tomorrow we all want to stop the tragic
loss of life along the migratory
routes and we all want to give
opportunities to our young
people so it's not only geography that
brings us together but also the
commitment to bring mutual benefits to
all our
people so we have to get
concrete and I'm very grateful to Italy
for putting cooperation with Africa at
the heart of the foreign
policy and of its G7
presidency the new M plan comes and as
an important contribution to this new
new phase of our
collaboration and it comes
complementary to our European global
gateway global gateway as you know is
the 150 billion Euro investment plan for
Africa and this is plain and simply team
Europe at
work today I would like to focus on
three issues where Europe and Africa
have agreed to work together and where
Italy
engagement can really make a difference
First Energy and
climate second education and skills and
third
migration on my first point energy and
climate today only 2% of global
investments in clean energy go to
Africa this is
sobering this is very sobering giving
Africa immense potential as a clean
energy
Powerhouse Africa has the space the wind
the sun just to name a few what it lacks
is
infrastructure but together we can
change
this with global gateway we aim to bring
clean energy to 100 million people who
currently don't have access to
energy this can turn out as a double
win Africa can not only produce enough
clean energy to power up the African
continent but also to create revenues by
exporting preparations have begun for
example to build the First underwater
electricity cable linking North Africa
to Italy and the rest of
Europe and for example our new hydrogen
bank is now open to African producers
this means good jobs energy energy
security for both Africa and
Europe my second Point global gateway
has a strong focus on building the local
skills that Africa
needs we are already at work to train
skills for manufacturing vaccines it has
been said in Randa Ghana
Sagal we are training the world
Workforce in Kenya and Namibia to
produce clean
hydrogen and here is the first example
for the complimentarity with the mate
plan Italy plays an active role over 50
Italian
universities have exchange programs now
with their African counterparts the
University of Parma for example
coordinates the arasmus project to
develop clean energy skills in Africa
and we want to invest in this kind of
cooperation for instance we are now
financing a high-speed data connection
between southern Europe and all Northern
African countries from Morocco and
Algeria to Egypt it will link
universities and data centers and this
allows joint research and Joint business
on the two sh shores of the
Mediterranean and what I really like
about this project is it is not only an
investment in Africa's talent but also
in the people in friendship and in the
next generation of our two
continents and this leads me to my third
point on migration we must crack down on
Smugglers who trade on human life
Smugglers put hundreds of thousands of
lives at Peril they amass young men in
the back of trucks across the desert
they abuse young women along the rout
and they put all of them on rickety
boats that are simply not made for the
high
seas we have to stop that callous
business and the best way to do this is
to join forces and crack down on the
criminals and in parallel to build legal
alternatives to the deadly smuggling
routs We Must Destroy the smuggers Web
of Lies in recent months we have been
working closely with for example Ivory
Coast Gambia ginaa marania and S Sagal
on our common approach that is clear to
save lives and to create
opportunities we offer more
opportunities to come to Europe legally
so that people can move learn and bring
their new expertise back home and we
cooperate on the return of irregular
migrants because Mobility must be
managed by law and not by the Smugglers
and the better we are on legal
migration the more convincing we are on
preventing irregular
migration ladies and
gentlemen enrio mate was a great Italian
and a great European and a true friend
of Africa he understood before others
that your strength is our strength and
vice versa and his legacy lives on today
our continents are building a true
win-win partnership with benefits for
Africa for Europe and the world so let's
keep up the good work there's aot lot to
do thank you very much for your
attention thank you very
much thank you prime minister Maloney
excellencies ladies and gentlemen it is
indeed a pleasure to be here with you to
today and I thank the leadership of
prime minister Malone and the government
of Italy for hosting this Summit in this
aost house of the people I believe that
two things unite each of us here today A
conviction that my continent Africa
holds near boundless potential and we've
heard that from all speakers today